170 000 people picked up along the u.s
border just last month
the migrant crisis is rapidly spinning
out of control
and the biden administration is
scrambling to deal with it
[Music]
and the current plan dollars and lots of
them in the form of foreign aid
president biden wants to try and buy our
way out of his border crisis with
taxpayer money
the administration is spending 60
million dollars a week
and now wants to launch a cash transfer
program in central america
this insults millions of americans who
are out of work in our country
the plan is for billions of dollars to
go to guatemala honduras and el salvador
now it's not exactly clear how this is
going to work but the white house
insists it won't be just direct cash
payments to potential migrants
the one thing i can promise you is the
u.s government isn't going to be handing
out money or checks to people
let's not forget that back in 2009 the
usa worked to topple the government of
honduras
ushering in a decade of instability and
chaos
let's also remember that guatemala has
had various
u.s backed military regimes so what
exactly led to this stampede toward the
u.s border the trail goes straight back
to the white house
the united states moral leadership on
refugee issues
was a point of bipartisan consensus for
so many decades when i first got here
we shined the light of lamp on of
liberty
on oppressed people we offered safe
havens for those fleeing violence or
persecution and our example pushed other
nations
to open wide their doors as well it's
not exactly clear what the end goal is
and there's not really a record of
success here
foreign aid to u.s aligned regimes in
central america that have free market
economies
is certainly not a new concept in fact
the u.s state department has been
showering the region with money for
decades
750 million dollars was provided to
central american countries
between 2014 and 2017. now the stated
goals of all that foreign aid was
roughly the same as what biden is
proposing
and people remained poor desperate and
they continued fleeing in 2019 donald
trump took the dramatic move of
halting usaid so can we continue to just
throw money at a problem and expect it
to eventually be solved
biden will soon be celebrating his 100th
day in office and he's got a major
crisis on his hands
with no end in sight caleb maupin rt
new york